[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Ali AKA George
Kareem in Lockwood and Co on Netflix
we're going to be talking spoilers about
the whole scene so make sure you watch
the season first how you doing today Ali
yeah good thank you thanks for having me
yeah man I'm so excited to talk to you I
absolutely love this show and what's my
favorite thing about this show is just
the Chemistry Between You Ruby and
Cameron
um this show doesn't work if that
doesn't like totally click and it does
so did you guys have to do chemistrys at
first like did you have kind of like
auditions together
yeah we did I remember I first met Ruby
actually in a chemistry read with me and
Ruby and another actor for Lockwood and
then I think that the powers that be
felt that that wasn't quite working so
then we had Cameron in and we did a few
reads with me Ruby and Cameron and then
they all seemed a lot happier and then
it came to be
yeah man and it's so cool to see how it
came to be it's great and was it in
general an intense auditioning process
to get the part of George being from
this popular book series and did you
only audition for George
yeah so
this it was the biggest thing that I'd
ever been up for and it probably still
is
um and it was very intense I'd say I had
about 10 auditions around January yeah
from January to like May of 2021 which
was when I got the role and I'd say the
last four of them were just chemistry
reads of kind of finding new like
finding the best kind of free to work
with each other and in answer to your
second question no George was always the
one that I went up for
um I was so intrigued by him initially
and I really love him as a character
yeah it's like the role is just like
made for you it's great and it's just
it's interesting too when we first meet
George it's Through The Eyes of Lucy so
did you go have a backstory in your head
of like pre-loosy time like whatever
George and Lockwood were up to in that
time like how that partnership kind of
came to be yeah it's I mean it's great
it's a great question it's something
that me and Cameron spoke about a lot
with the writers
um obviously we know that George got
fired from Fitz initially
um
and I think one thing that Joe Cornish
wanted to make very clear was that these
two were very as in these two as in
George and Lockwood were very close and
it was almost like a bromance between
them and George particularly loved
working with Lockwood which is why maybe
he's so hostile when Lucy comes because
someone might be threatening this
romance that he has
I like that answer yeah that makes a lot
of sense and I think it's cool because
when we're meeting George we're seeing
you know he cooks he's stressed clean
he's walking around in his pajamas were
a lot of these character choices from
the books or were they from like already
in the script or did you make some of
these choices yourself
so a lot stress cleaning was an addition
from the writers of the show
um but there's a lot of things that I
found to be very true to the books so
for example there's the biscuit Rule and
George kind of the chef of the house
um obviously you have the nice edition
of George being Iranian so you know you
have George cooking call me sad Z for
Lockwood in episode two which I think is
really special and I love
um so I think it's a nice mix that
hopefully fans of the books and wider
audiences can enjoy yeah and that's the
way to go right where you honor the
books a lot but there's a lot of your
own and for the show its own voice which
is great and can you or can you not
confirm that your portrayal of George
was somewhat inspired by Egon from
Ghostbusters I'm seeing the semblance
with the glass and the hair research you
know so that's
I had never thought about Egon um but I
remember actually on our third block of
shooting our first assistant director
said
you've really remind me of Egon and I I
had seen Ghostbusters but I couldn't put
a name to the face
um so it's funny you say that too but
initially I think my first Inspirations
for George when I was auditioning for
him were kind of Ben whistle's queue in
the recent James Bond films and also
kind of like Richard ayode in
particularly in the IT Crowd
oh wow yeah those are two great uh
Inspirations that's yeah that's awesome
so that's cool that you have a little
blend of that and then uh it's
interesting I'm just thinking about
episode three there's just like ghost
battling that's really intense with the
blood dripping on the walls really
really exciting scene what are you
exactly seeing on set when all that is
going down
yeah that's another great question it
was like
in all honesty we're seeing nothing like
we
we were told beforehand and kind of
shown on an iPad what kind of vibe it
would be and what the final product
would kind of look like
um but on the day you really just got to
imagine it and
yeah I mean we had a few puppeteers who
would kind of do the close-up shots but
other than that no we had nothing for
the red one I like that that's funny and
it's interesting though too like how did
you feel with like the iconic Rapier
like did you have to train with that
thing like what what was your
comfortability with it
so yeah we all had about let's say eight
weeks of Sword training before the shoot
yeah and um
I think initially I was so out of my
thoughts with it I didn't know what the
hell I was doing but we had such a great
stun team that they made me feel me and
I know for sure Cameron and Ruby feel so
comfortable with the rapiers and
yeah I mean by the end I found it so
much fun yeah it's and it's really fun
the audience seeing this too like I
think that's what makes it like special
in the ghost hunting genre is having
these Rapier so it's cool they kept them
for the show uh now George also what
stood out for me was the end of episode
four is this big monologue you know he
puts Kip's crew in their place and he
kind of shows off his smarts here which
I like and his bravery so like is that a
type of scene though as an actor like
you tossed and turned the night before
thinking about it like okay this is a
big George scene or you kind of just go
with it like it doesn't scare you at all
it's actually the opposite I remember we
were filming so we had like two weeks of
night shoots in that Cemetery Kendall
green
and
you're you kind of you're filming the
night but you always have an eye out of
the scenes that to come in case you've
got to learn a lot of lines I remember
when I saw that it was like the next day
in the schedule and I was reading the
scripts and
I actually found that it was so well
written and such a great moment for
George which is a character that I love
that I was so excited for it and
I remember it for me it was one of my
favorite scenes to film because it's
such a great moment for George it was so
much fun and will McGregor gave me so
much freedom to kind of just do whatever
I wanted with it
yeah no it is it's a great scene and you
kill it in that moment which was cool
um I'm also wondering too what was cool
about the character of George is like I
feel like you have like almost the most
fun part to play because the second half
of this season you know we're seeing
this possessed version of George did you
guys film that in like order like did
you do regular George then possess
George was that challenging like how did
that kind of go about yeah I mean that's
another really great question because we
we didn't film
anything in order really because we
actually filmed episode eight where
George is in the kind of the crypt with
Joplin that's what we filmed first that
was my first week oh my God yeah
um
so it was one thing that we really had
to establish was a sense of consistency
and how it kind of gets worse for George
so I remember a few times there'd be a
moment where one of the executive
producers or the director would be like
no Ali I think this is too intense for
George I think you need to dial it down
or the other way around Ali I think you
need to dial it up so
yeah I think the key thing was just to
make sure that there was consistency and
we knew where George had come from and
we know where George was going to go
with this kind of possessiveness
yeah and that's impressive that you had
to jump right into like some of the most
intense stuff at the start that that's
pretty crazy and um I'm also wondering
too I don't know if I completely read
this wrong but I'm gonna go for it but
did um you just mentioned uh Mrs Joplin
so did did George ever have like
feelings for her was there any
attraction for him to Mrs Joplin I was
trying to figure that out in my head and
I'm not sure maybe you have the answer
well it
we really play it on like a
like on the fence
um what I what I will say for sure is in
the original scripts when we did the
read through
they definitely played into the kind of
romantic element of that relationship
more than you've seen in the series okay
hopefully in the like the flat scene in
episode five and also just the way
Joplin interacts with George in episode
eight
um
for me I think ultimately if you boil it
down George really does admire Joplin as
someone who he feels seen by someone who
he respects academically
um so ultimately it is a very special
relationship to him yeah and he has he
has a lot of special relationships and
then we get to see it kind of really
like Bloom with flow
um and there's this big moment like
where he hesitates to go with flow and
it's references flow inherons right like
is he is that something that he you feel
like he's always going to regret not
immediately gone with her in that moment
I think so yeah I
yeah
I mean I think he realizes how special
flow
is and I think he definitely will and
does feel guilt for how he treated her
on the boat
um
but yeah flow is probably one of the
most emotionally mature and strongest
characters that we have in the series
and I think George realizes that
um
so I mean we'll see what happens if we
hopefully get future Seasons oh for sure
and uh
also too I forgot to even ask this but I
was also curious just in that realm of
what you're seeing on set you know it's
amazing about this Trio of you guys but
there's also kind of like a fourth wheel
with the Talking Heads calling the job
what what is what's going on there is
there an actor there is it just a thing
you're looking at what is that yes so
the skull is actually it's a prop and
bless Ruby because it's filled with
water and it's really heavy and she had
to carry that round for a long like a
lot of shoot days
um
but it's kind of it's got these LED
lights in it and which kind of Flash
um and some days Michael the voice of
the skull would come in with a
microphone and do the lines offset some
days it would be like the director or
the assistant director doing the lines
um
yeah I mean it I'd say I have to say the
VFX looks so amazing but the prop as it
was initially still looks so great oh
that yeah that's really cool
um to hear and yeah it's an awesome just
character in the show uh yeah so you
mentioned like a future season if a
season two were to happen
um is there anything on your wish list
like you'd hope to maybe be explored
with George or something that you'd be
excited to kind of do without like
spoiling books but just like in general
for sure
um
I'd love to see
George get closer to that dream he has
of kind of working out how the problem
started
um because that's something that means
so much to him
um I'd also think it'd be exciting to
see
now Lucy's kind of settled into into the
agency her taking more ownership and
maybe even her kind of like saving the
boys more
um
and obviously it'd be exciting to see
what happens with George and Flo if they
choose to explore that further yeah I
love all those points and yeah I really
hope this show gets a season two so
everybody keep watching this watch Ali
crush it and lock with a call on Netflix
now tell your friends about it family
everybody it's so good Ali thanks for
being an absolute pleasure to talk to
and I hope to include the future one day
thanks so much Steve I mean your
questions are amazing honestly oh thank
you that means a lot uh have a great one